i think the
the polygamous relationships we're gonna
see is like one guy with like multiple
girls and then one girl with like
multiple guys
because the way the dating market is
today it's like a very small percentage
of men have access to all the women
and so and then
and then there's like the bot so it's
like 20 of men have access to 80 of
women and the other 80 percent of men
are fighting over 20 of women
like roughly all women like one man
because because now that women like make
more money we want a guy that makes more
than us and i've never understood that
well there's there's biological
reasonings for the reasons we feel the
way we feel so it's not necessarily all
our fault so a big double standard i
hear for like women and men and someone
submitted this on my instagram his body
count right like if a guy sleeps with a
lot of girls he's more valuable a girl
vice versa right but the reason that
that is is because over the course of
human history like men had to ensure
paternity so they but biologically like
you can't really help that they're
attracted like work for all this and you
don't know it's your child like yeah
yeah
and it's we're in a different time now
because we have birth control so that
completely changed the game but we
didn't have that over the course of
human history we can't ask men to just
change their biology that's how they
feel and it's the same thing with women
because we had to find the highest
possible mate that we could
so in over the course of human history
like you wanted a guy that had slept
with more girls because that like then
he would have been able to protect those
girls it was a form of pre-selection
does that make sense and it's the same
thing with um income we want a guy
that's more competent than us so he
could protect us and take care of us so
we have security and that's why the
secretary
yeah and i'm not saying it's realistic
in this day and age because like women
are making more and more money there's
only so many men but that's why we see
polygamy because girls would rather
share a guy that makes more money than
have a god that's not really then that's
like they feel is below them okay i
cannot agree with that i think um